it is time for our very special pop quiz
so since it's pop quiz week we're going
big we've got this fabulous money booth
here for one special audience member to
step into and grab all the cash they can
there's also two special tickets in
there tell us about them ryan well if
you grab the gold ticket you win a grand
prize and if you grab the silver ticket
the entire audience will go home with a
special prize
all right so pay attention
where is
tiffany stately
there you are
[Applause]
okay
[Applause]
thank you so much for having me i'm so
excited you guys you have no idea how
much
this means to me and how you know i'm
i'm going to do my thing in here i'm
going to try to see you know what i can
do because it's been rough the pandemic
has
set me back so much i'm a single mom and
i got a ton of things a ton of bills
credit card bills different things that
i'm behind in
activities for my kid you know um so i
am so grateful i don't care if i get
twenty dollars out of here
i know it's really gonna help i know
you're gonna get at least twenty dollars
in there oh i want you to get so much
money
all right hey guys thank you so much
okay we're going to ask you three
questions of trivia that you hopefully
have heard
and remembered throughout the show
and with every question answered right
that's an extra 10 seconds in the booth
all right here we go tiffany are you
ready all right yes okay first question
who was the number one favorite
celebrity among america's teens
according to insider first up who is the
number one favorite celebrity amongst
america's teens
who is it it's adam sandler oh
i know
adamson
okay
okay guys
go ahead
second question for 10 more seconds in
the booth what is the name of the book
that pilar and drew have written it's a
cookbook our cookbook
is out today
[Music]
rebel home homemaker
[Music]
[Applause]
and final question do you remember alex
cooper's mother's name
your mom is here by the way i can't help
but say hello to laurie hi lori
[Applause]
hurt with shards of cash
and um put on the apron please so your
strategy grab stuff like your life
depends on it okay
get in
all right let's go
[Applause]
[Applause]
okay perfect oh gosh tiffany
how do you feel
i feel so good
i think i'm doing pretty good
we're gonna count the money and go to a
quick commercial break and give the
amount when we come right back stick
around to find out
[Applause]
welcome back okay before the break
tiffany had 30 seconds because she got
all three questions right to collect as
much money as she could in our money
booth tiffany are you ready to find out
how much you won yes
all right tiffany you wanted to win over
20 right yes that was the goal
tiffany you won 1070.
[Applause]
it is so our pleasure but you know what
i heard you know you saying that you had
a difficult year and i just i got it
[Music]
i just gotta tell you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm on my knees a lot in this show
by the way whatever that totals you'll
keep but it'll be a total of five
thousand dollars
[Applause]
thank you so much thank you guys for
having me here thank you for allowing me
to participate
this year has been so rough i mean just
being here in the audience and just
being here with you is it it just makes
all the difference in the world and i
have the money and
to know that i have a little bit more
comfort ahead like
it means everything thank you so much
tiffany that that's not all
you remember that little golden ticket
that was in there yes well you grabbed
it which means you get a grand prize as
well
you're going to win a massage chair from
traumatic value to three thousand
dollars
[Applause]
and if that's not enough you also got
the silver dollar
every member of our audience will go
home with a 150 jewelry gift card from
electric picks
[Applause]
congratulations tiffany and thank you so
much for sharing your story with us it's
so meaningful for us to be on your
journey and get a window inside your
life and thank you thank you thank you
for hearing me thank you for having me
here i appreciate it so much we hear you
we feel you and we appreciate you thank
you so much
thank you tiffany
thank you so much congratulations and
thank you to every one of you for
choosing to spend your time with us we
make this show for you
[Applause]
[Music]
you